today's video is sponsored by surfshark
vpn how you feeling today i'm feeling
great
i'm wearing purple funky pants
yes
[Laughter]
hello hi you feel comfortable ranking
people's attractiveness
oh yeah like my parents would say
i don't know what it's like to be shy
that really helped me a lot
with my modeling career oh you used to
model
i modeled for about six years
but now i'm a mother of five and
hey this is me now i love it okay let's
bring our first person in
well hello there hello you seem very
confident
i think i'm confident about the way i
look the world
they will like you a little bit skinnier
okay all right if your body shape
matches
your height people would not see your
weight
with your confidence and the way you
look i'll give you a seven
other than the weight is there anything
else that i can improve on
when you walk because i'm not touching
the weight these double burgers
i'm eating them fries
large please you know what i think the
coke extra large thank you
gummy bears all day popcorn with butter
you know you know what i think it's
surprising to them how candy she is and
how like systematic like
yeah you're too fat like there's no
i'm going to ease you in you know what i
mean it's like just no lube right into
that nobody's seeing it
just she just [ __ ] pop it in right i
respect it because this is the point of
the video
but i think for people who are
participating they're just not ready for
help yeah
lunch is because the thing that happened
i think it's because of
two things where she's from
and the modeling clear because the
modeling
when you do modeling it's ruthless like
that exactly yeah
no no no this is not gonna do
can we get another one and they treat
you like a no you like you're you're
talking about you
like you're not there so when you walk
your confidence let it come out when you
walk
like oh well i don't know people will
see that
that's great okay okay thank you
how you feeling today i'm feeling great
i'm wearing purple funky pants
yes
[Laughter]
i'm wearing a purple funky pen the
moment he said that i'm like he she's
going to tear his ass up
i wear purple funky pants yes about
those we're going right there
yes this is one of those dudes that
pretends like they're too cool for
school but if you said some [ __ ] they
gonna be in their feelings
i'm wearing purple funky pants
[Music]
yes they are funky all right it doesn't
go together
shows me that you're very comfortable
but stay comfortable in your house
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's exactly what you said it's
exactly what you said
when the chin went down womp womp
that that [ __ ] went
[ __ ] that she's good and that
definitely has to go
so five wow
damn your insight is very good in some
situations but honestly like i don't
give a flying [ __ ] if this is just like
my drip
and i still love myself so you got hurt
it's what you said that's exactly what
the [ __ ] you said i still love myself so
it was his way of telling her to [ __ ]
off without telling her to [ __ ] off
that's what happened right there yeah
but honestly like
i don't give a flying [ __ ] i can tell
i can tell oh the the comeback was great
because i still love myself
no no it's not that i don't give a [ __ ]
i love myself yeah i can tell
i can tell you don't give up i could
tell you don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean that's what that is
that the comeback that [ __ ] up
she's perfect with the comeback i like
this great job because
see that that's my girl
hi hi how are you good she's going to
demolish her
oh i don't want to see this
i oh wow i want to see this
how are you i am wonderful you
have a beautiful face thank you the
smile
really helps but you should not dress
like your mother
when she
wait no go wait wait no
we're in canada yeah it's winter yeah
it's cold
yeah so you did not get a couple degrees
warmer right there
yeah well you heard that then you feel a
little bit of oh yeah a burn
yeah you know what i got in the kitchen
what you got pepto bismol
yo her i like her man she tells the
truth i'm mad at her
man if she was doing the kony2012
documentary she was like we're never
going to catch him but i'll take your
money
she don't lie like i appreciate that
i would give you a six okay
why am i giving you a six you may ask
yes i i would like to
[Laughter]
she did it was like uh i'm giving you a
six
so you're asking why i'm giving you a
six no yeah you're asking so i'm giving
you a six because
yo that's great you need to show your
figure
because you have a beautiful figure
inside that big thing
thank you okay so take off the glasses
let me see
perfect better oh my god yes okay you
have a good figure you have a good
face so enhance a little bit okay okay
thank you okay thank you well hello
there i'm nathan how you doing oh good
wow that is good what are we here
to do uh you are here to
check this out okay so i can see
that you take care of yourself
i would give you a nine and why why
would you give me that thing because
when you came out of that door i knew
that you have the sparks
that shows that you're very confident
it's good
oh thank you all right perfect thank you
thank you appreciate it
keep up the good one
it's like keep up the good work she's
not shy to say the bad stuff and she's
not shy to say the good stuff
and then what ends up happening this is
really what ends up happening
is that when you're not when you don't
lie and you're honest
and forthcoming about your criticisms it
makes your compliments mean that much
more yeah of course
people that are always so blasting like
oh my god cindy always look beautiful
after a while those words they don't
mean much it's like a girl that always
says i love you for everything
it's like when it's like she says i love
you i love you i love you oh my god i
love pumping
pumpkin spice latte i love this i love
this i love these boots i love you love
everything so but when your dad tells
you i love you the first time
it [ __ ] you up because it means so much
more literally i was literally going
there
i always be like yo [ __ ] let me in tag
me and you like nah
stone cold steve austin
went but when yeah but yeah that's what
it is it's just that it is what it is
i love you i love you i love you love
you you hear it every time
i agree today's video is sponsored by
surf shark and vpn
a vpn is just an application or a web
extension that you could use
on your internet browser to mask your ip
address to change
the location of your ip you might be
like yo but i like where i live
the block is hot what happens when you
want to watch a tv show
and it says we don't offer it to people
in your country what you're going to do
who are you going to call not
ghostbusters right i'll try to watch
a tv show in the uk so i was like hey
man let me in
and they said no no nobody from canada
so i changed my ipad address using
surfsharkvpn
all of a sudden bruh i'm from brixton
wagon and now if you sign up with the
promo code
abba and preach you get 84 off for the
next four months
get our surfshark vpn deal using the
link in the description below
i'm joanna joanna you seem nervous are
you shy
i i guess i'm a little bit reserved i
can tell
you'll feel intimidated unfortunately
we'll give you a five
oh okay first of all you need to change
that glasses it doesn't look very good
on you should i take my foster stuff do
you want to see that you can take it off
yeah
would that make it better when you took
out the glasses i went to a seven
okay looking at you you're not very tall
how has that affected
your life people either see me as a
child basically
or they don't give me like the respect
that i think i should get you can be a
firecracker
bring out that personality that will
make people not see your hair yeah
and you know what she does without the
classes
uh and she's not lying she's not lying
she's not lying she took the glasses
down
[Music]
it's crazy because i know if i went to
the comments some people probably view
this as mean
but she's one giving people what they
came to ask for
and two she's doing it from a place of
like this is to better you it's not to
hurt you there's a difference between
like you look ugly and be like hey man
if you switched up that thing it matches
your shoes a lot better or the shoes i
saw you with last week
it doesn't hurt to hear that the choices
that you made aren't that great
kinda but it's to make you better
there's a difference between criticism
and a roast
that's not a roast no exactly height
but see who you are you know what i mean
yeah i think that's perfect
could you turn around a little bit
okay i like your dress it looks very
good on you
i can tell you have the eye lashes
done doesn't really give you
the ten eight how would i get a nine
you're a natural beauty person you need
to enhance what you have
but not add artificial to it do
something
about the nails i always have them super
long
i can type with them i can do hair with
them wow
okay if it works for you it works for
you thank you
you know what this is oh you know what
this is what this is what kevin samuel
should have done
and they're happy they're happy but
[Music]
they don't know the car that i came in
with right i don't want it
that is good look at you look at it
you look good thank you so you take good
care of yourself i can tell
i like the hair i like the way that you
portray
who you are that is very attractive
eight okay what you need to turn down
okay she made the same noise girls make
when they're like how do you rate my
blood my bj's and i'm like
7 out of 10 and they go okay um
how do i get to a 9 or 10. i was i've
been told that i was better than that
yeah yeah well they were lying
yeah they say okay but it's really like
not okay
yeah it's not but she's eight she's good
it's eight is good
don't act like eight is not good eight
is good but
but that could be a 9.
they they don't want to say 10. you want
to know why they want to say 10 yeah
because dan makes you sound too
concerned exactly two nine is like he
did nine is like i'm not perfect but i'm
pretty
like it's perfect to me exactly eight
i'm below that
what you would suggest because what i
need
i already do okay what do you do for a
living
i have an online store with some cute
accessories and
thrifted fines like say somebody goes to
your site
and see what you do and want to meet
with you if you wanna
show that spunk of professionalism
you need to first try to take that out
well i'm telling you i only keep jobs
that let me keep my nose ring
well then you're limiting yourself to
who you are
i'm aligning myself with what is in
alignment with me
okay and they the nails beautiful
but they're too long she's like
yeah you you're limiting yourself no i'm
in line with myself
okay the nails i'm not
there's not disgusting i just said what
i said i'm not going to keep
we agreed or disagreed fight good
whatever works now i'm moving on to
something else the nails
i like to work with you well too long
to work with you not just my dear people
like you
[Music]
well i feel like she's arguing with what
her mother's always said to her
and she's like no [ __ ] you're not going
to have it yeah because nah
[Music]
if you say so
how was that it's me i
tell it the way it is i try not to be
too insulting most of the advice or what
i tell people
if they twig it and make it work for
them
they'll be very successful in life and
also
whatever they decide to do i i love the
yo
listen i gotta bless this woman yo i
gotta apply
i gotta that's a that's the first time
that i
learned and i get something from the cut
this woman
there's a lot of things of the way she's
uh she is that i have to apply
you know what his biggest one is what
craig david
walking away yeah but she lets other
people walk away
no but she walks away from the point
yeah you know when they start they yeah
they're starting the yeah i'm walking
okay yeah i don't
i don't need to it's like i don't need
to approve the way she does it is like
she doesn't need to prove anything
less or so she doesn't need to prove
anything she's great
okay you this isn't that that no it's
not okay
so and this isn't it no it's not sure
what this is the first time that i
really
am gonna take something from the cut and
apply it this woman
is amazing some people are mad we've got
a lot of dislikes 2000 dislikes
i mean listen it is what is i think i
think
you know the interesting thing about
this is that she gave so many
compliments as well
take the girl with the glasses she said
take off your glasses your
face is naturally beautiful your finger
is you don't have to hide underneath
that big
shawl or whatever it's like she was
saying nice things as well like i said
balance there's you're an [ __ ] if all
you say is negative things to people
obviously or negative things that are
not sometimes things are negative right
but if you're just saying negative
things out of spite yeah it's also that
different
the thing that happened is that the way
human beings and human brains
is is that we just often focus on the
negative example i was giving a show it
was opening for someone
and it's like it's a theater right
there's a thousand five hundred
and fifteen fifteen hundred
[ __ ] in the place fifteen
hundred people in the place
everybody is laughing there's one dude
in front his arms are crossed and he's
not laughing
i'm focusing on this dude yeah whenever
when everybody else is laughing then i
go backstage
the guy i'm opening for is like yo
what's up how was it it's great but
there's that one dude
that was the one dude arm arm cross
uh and not laughing and this dude that
i'm opening for
he's 25 years in the business and the
first 45 minutes of his set
he was focusing on that dude too even
after 45
after 25 to focus on he was still on the
negative
right and after that he was able to like
he was able to get off that like you
know what [ __ ] this dude yeah right yeah
or play with it and stuff like that but
that's how the human brain works
we focus often more on the negative than
the positive yeah but
you know otherwise i thought this video
is great um i think she handles
um honest feedback and criticism the way
i think i handle it within my
relationships my friends know not to
come to me
for empty compliments they come to be
for honest feedback that's the
relationship that we've built that we
understand i'm so ugly
yes [ __ ] you are yeah and with
strangers if they come to me like hey
what do you think about this
i don't want to look at it please i
really want i'm like no you don't want
me to look at it
and like all right look at it i'm like
all right so if you ask for it it's
trash
and sometimes and if it's good i promise
you i will give them the utmost respect
and compliments when when people get
complimentary like damn okay i really
that means i'm like no problem i have no
problem saying nice things to people if
i really feel it but i just won't lie to
people
to placate them and if i have nothing
nice to say i just won't say anything
but if you
insist i'll tell you the truth oh and
i've seen it happen and he's like that
yeah
and if i tell you the truth don't be out
there crying about her being salty it's
just like bruh
you're a grown-ass person you asked for
something you asked twice
you asked a third time well [ __ ] when
you get your present from santa
don't be sad when it's exactly what you
put on you signed up for this people
that went there signed up for this you
understand
they it's not like they didn't know what
they were going into you know they
signed up for it
so yeah you signed up for someone to
judge you be be prepared
you might not they might not see you how
you see yourself
exactly so that's pretty much it for
today's video we want to hear your
thoughts what do you guys think about
this video
by all means tell us
[Music]
you